die am themen sind leute report report
report ist gesehen die stand nebenan
haben sich nicht angegriffen
josef skills und herzlich willkommen zur
zweiten folge minecraft shorts für alle
die die erst vor gericht gesehen haben
minecraft ist ein format in dem ich mein
kreft spiele und das so gut wie es geht
runter karte auf so wenig wie möglich
heute spielen wir sg 64 und ich würde
sagen wir legen doch direkt mal los naja
ok ist ein ganz guter start jetzt ein
bisschen rüstung so grace period vorbei
und das mit den hier sehr gut so der wir
jetzt bieten uns kann er bekommen aber
erst ein bisschen regen und nächster
gegner da hinten schon desaster vielen
50m haster verläuft weil die er
verursacht jetzt in disaster mit seiner
holz axt und komplett ohne rüstung ist
auch weg hatten gold apfel weil es kein
gold
partnerships bei stiggy x3 was geht
steht wie wenn dir der fixabsteiger logo
auch konnten so schlecht laufen die
kills laufen als hätten sie beim laufen
als wie treppen vergleich für die kills
laufen rein die kills laufen wie punkt
ab dass meine kommentare der beste
kommentar gewinnt einen schoko eis aber
gut ist richtig schokoeis mit
zartbitterschokolade des presse ok 16
leute noch wird knapp die runde auf
jeden fall zwei minuten erst aufgenommen
und sind auf 16 15 leute nur noch das
ist halt irgendwas club gerade meine war
irgendwas hat in die wand gebracht aber
von der seite wo eigentlich nicht sein
kann dass der aufzug hinter den
schranktüren also hier drüben da drüben
kommt auf einmal zum geräusch als würde
jemand ein gummiball gegen die wand
werfen oder so aber hat kann niemanden
gummiball gegen die wand werfen oder
frank alter spruch bei mir als folter
reist roßkopf ist da leute seht das
cockpit wenn ich zum kran komme probiere
ich eventuell des mrg aus aber erst am
ende
wobei ja ok dahin ist einer da ist der
boj
der pfeiler der pfeiler wir müssen die
aufsammeln ok einnahme aufgesammelt oder
kommt direkt in die ecke schießt
aufpassen jetzt hat er noch keine
ein herz nicht verloren auf jeden fall
versuchen ja okay dass sie wohlauf hieß
es dort
ich hab gedacht ihr wolltet tanker
einsetzen wollte er wahrscheinlich auch
aber hat sie nicht gefunden
ok auf jeden fall haben jetzt erstmal
ein kompass ganz wichtig und darüber
hinaus letschin rüstung beziehe auch mal
den eisen helm für alle die sich immer
beschwert ist ein eisen helmholtz damit
in gold ab klasse 7 b hass der kompass
xx teams verboten ihres netzes dürftig
team des teams verboten wie am themen
sind leute report report report ist
gesehen die standen dem dann haben sich
nicht angegriffen
es ist einfach teams verbote oder [ __ ]
sicher nicht alter alters matches hier
klein ist matches wie sie sich nicht
angreifen es ist ihm verboten
ich habe es aber aufgenommen leute ok
trotzdem hilft uns alles nichts wir
müssen versuchen zu überleben
jetzt läuft der jetzt 42 vereinen läuft
dann läuft er direkt der boj
nice und er ist doch okay ich hab den
ersten geholt und der andere wowereit
email rover sind email aufpassen
ok der nächste gegner es vor mir wieder
vorne auch am team-titel kindern
der name alter schwede
okay er trifft im fallen ich trete für
eine runde weiter deathmatch oder 50
sekunden
aber ihr habt gerade ihm gesehen leute
ihr habt es gesehen die haben auf jeden
fall
bettina für mich zumindest so aus
schreibt meine kommentare was ihr davon
haltet haben die getan haben die nicht
gezähmt und falls ihr findet die haben
ihren betrieb ein reporter die auch
gerne gehabt die namen ja hier benutzt
gerne das video schickte es anders
kommen
die hektischen schickt es an das gold
team gerne mit meiner zustimmung
die kindergartenkinder okay was mache
ich mit dem
robert park park
oh ich hab ihn nicht ab in die kabine
alter schwede
holy [ __ ] in ein geistig bekommen sehr
gut
alter schwede der box nicht bekommen es
war und wie es mit schiller man allzu
schwer erst mal recken wie viele gegner
gibt es noch nur noch den einen hier
ok alles klar das ist gut das ist gut es
gibt es die spenden der mitte das will
ich mir eventuell holen ja klar wir
brauchen die tränke nicht fest ob marcel
philipp track mit alter deshalb dauern
warum geht ihr nicht dauern
länger dauern als ich wieder wieder
übertreibt der ehegatte viehtränke der
schon die pfeifen es okay jetzt aber
auch dauern
holy shit to noise runde auf jeden fall
die war richtig knapp
die war richtig kurz und knackig sieben
minuten haben wir aufgenommen
ich würde mal sagen ich kannte das mal
so runter das heißt es wird eine relativ
kurze folge wahrscheinlich für ihre fünf
minuten lang aber es war sicher sicher
sich an der nachfolge
deswegen lässt gern einen daumen nach
oben da wenn ich das gefallen hat und
schreiben die kommentare war das ein
team oder nicht eure meinung in die
kommentare
wir sehen zum nächsten video wieder rein
macht's gut